[Musique]
loin de la capitale et du village
olympique le cœur des JO 2024 va battre
en Berry la ville de 43000 habitants
part avec deux ans de retard dans
l'organisation par rapport aux autres
sites la course contre la montre est
lancée le territoire n'a jamais
accueilli un tel événement les services
de l'État sont sur le pont entre
appréhension et excitation
et sécurisations qui sont mises autour
du site vont être augmentés mais
derrière il y a en charge toute la
population
olympique que ce soit des athlètes aux
populations agrêtées délégation qui vont
se rendre sur le site media nous ne
pouvons pas avoir un événement qui
entacherait
les épreuves de quelques façons que ce
soit ce sont 6 à 700 compétiteurs qui
sont attendus 3 à 5000 personnes en tout
chaque jour entre juillet et septembre
sécurité secours mobilité santé rien
n'est laissé au hasard il faut pouvoir
prévoir l'imprévisible
on a des exercices pour se préparer
notamment bien sûr sur l'événement qui
est le plus dramatique un attentat des
exercices qui se jouent aussi en réel
nous avons des plans hors-sec pour les
catastrophes naturelles nous avons des
plans horselets de nombreuses victimes
nous avons une culture de la préparation
et c'est ce que nous mettons en oeuvre
actuellement aucun chiffre de renfort de
sécurité intérieure n'est avancé pour
l'instant à l'hôpital on se prépare déjà
une augmentation possible de 10 à 15%
des admissions pendant l'été mais les
jeux doivent rester une fête une fête
populaire
directement des JO on découvre un projet
qui correspond en fait au cahier des
charges de Paris 2024 l'idée c'est
vraiment de faire vivre au spectateur
une véritable expérience d'aller sur
site pour y trouver des animations de la
culture du sport bien évidemment
d'assister à l'ensemble des
retransmissions puisque c'est ça
l'objectif principal finalement du site
il y a plusieurs la possibilité voir
quel est le plus simple ça peut être
aussi que des que des fanions qui
descendent sur le parvis d'équinoxe une
fan zone sera donc installée city stade
plage restauration étrangère les JO
seront aussi dans le cœur de la ville
sur un site naturellement sécurisé la
difficulté avec le nombre de
prestataires présents si tu vas y avoir
beaucoup de choses cette année 2024
partout en France et on est déjà en
train de se dire que notamment voilà sur
des barrières h sur des écrans vidéo sur
ce genre de choses on est déjà très
limité il y a déjà plus beaucoup de
choses de disponibles dont on va essayer
d'avancer très très vite moi j'ai
positionnerais bien ici une sorte de
petit pôle sécu l'enjeu pour les
organisateurs et la collectivité sera
donc de sécuriser sans trop gêner la vie
quotidienne
l'idée c'est de maintenir la circulation
c'est de maintenir le parking Diderot
les accès l'idée c'est vraiment que les
Castells roussins et public en général
et pas de contraintes pour se déplacer
dans le centre-ville ou du moins le
moins possible
Châteauroux lance le pari de surfer sur
le plus grand événement sportif au monde
mais sans référence ni modèle ni
exemples puisque ce sera une première en
France